um what I didn't know is so you actually
so you went to HBC you went to Howard
and graduated course and then you ended
up coming to USC and getting a degree
here yeah was it a master's yeah uh
you're really smart uh somebody say that
yeah I'm a nerd so how many years of
college did you do is that like six I
did six well I did I did five uh I
finished my masters in a year but it was
a two-year program so what was your
master
by the way life Flex she's like I
finished my masters in the year it was a
two program I didn't want pay for the
other year I didn't want to pay for the
other year um but I did um Global
medicine Global medicine yeah so what
does that mean um it basically focuses
more so uh in like the administrative
side of things um so you can like work
for the UN or work for the wh or so you
could like be F fuch fouche's assistant
essentially yeah right but not that
delusional but yeah shout out to that
guy uh yo it's crazy like I wonder like
with your with your background like how
did you feel about like just the whole
vaccine and all that now that we're on
the other side of it yeah and it seems
like you know we kind of got like we
kind of got Bamboozled a little cuz I
got the jab but I feel like I I feel
like I If I Had have known everything I
know now I would have totally have just
been like if I get it it's probably
better if I just get it naturally yeah I
mean I knew then just from my background
that they didn't know the difference
between public health and Public Safety
and I think they were confusing the two
um but for me I I never got I never got
vaccinated because cuz you're young and
healthy well no I there's you know
comorbidities that exist in in anything
but I do think that for me I was like
there's a certain thing as her immunity
after a certain point in time everybody
has to get it it's it's inevitably going
to get you and if you have something
that's going to Def defeat you like if
you have a cancer or HIV or something
like that are you higher at risk to be
you know more sick then yes but that's
life this is the common flu yeah and
then the other thing yeah there's so
much we can get into
yeah I did get the I got the first jab I
didn't get the booster they couldn't
boost me okay but then I was by the time
I got the the the booster came around I
was like I don't know bro did you ever
have Co I had it [__] four times yeah
so see but you know it only it never was
bad for me though me neither like I had
it and well the first time I had it I
only knew cuz I couldn't smell okay and
so I remember my wife was cooking and my
wife can cook she's Mexican you know she
could cook should have been smelling
like so I was like sitting on the couch
I was playing video games or something
and I was just like oh you're cooking
and then I was like oh [__] they got me
so I walked outside to my patio and we
have like a little pad of grass and my
dog's poop on and I got on my knees and
I sniffed a turd I swear to God I didn't
put my nose to it but I didn't smell the
turd and I was like [__] I was like it
finally happened but again I also was
like running around going to Studio
sessions like I was like you outside for
sure yeah I mean for like the first
month I was inside enjoying it yeah
relaxing catching up on some Tiger King
you know I didn't get it for 2 years I
was I was one of them people that wore
masks everywhere didn't go out didn't
like I was I knew the the risk of I have
asthma so I was like okay let me just be
careful you being careful but yeah I got
it after 2 years and I was like
expecting a day to come like oh my God
I'm cuz my breathing is compromised so
I'm in a hotel like quarantine and like
what day is it going to be the worst day
and it never came went it was totally
fine I had a fever for one day and then
I just waited out the rest of it